[Musik]
der EU gestern Nacht in der UNO zu einem
dramatischen Schlagabtausch zwischen den
Konfliktparteien nach dem Scheitern der
diplomatischen bem der Grund für die
komplette Ausschaltung der
Luftraumüberwachung soll ein
geheitäfte vermuten dass das hochgiftige
Antrags über einen Brief Österreich
befindet sich bereits in einem
hybridkrieg mit irregulären die
Bundesregierung den Einsatz des
Bundesheeres zur militärischen
Landesverteidigung beschlossen
wir sind eben alarmiert worden für die
Sicherung des Kraftwerkes sind mit die
Hubschrauber abkt
worden es ist Hal der Vorteil für uns
Jäger dadurch dass wir luftbeweglich
sind eben schnell von A nach B kommen
und schnell eingesetzt werden können der
Schutz der kritischen Infrastruktur also
Verkehr Energie und Versorgung der
Bevölkerung ist eine der Hauptaufgaben
des bundeshers auch gegen Sabotage
Terror oder
Cyberangriffe Name Oberwachtmeister
hartlip jägerguppen Kommandant wir
kriegen das Gerät noch den extra
Hubschrauber sprich Munition sonstige
Ausrüstung und sicherern jetzt eben das
[Musik]
Kraftwerk mein Name ist nadtin
feuerhuber ich bin derzeit Kommandant
dienbetrieb in der weiteren Verwendung
werde dann im militärischen cyberzentrum
sein das heutige Szenario hat beinhaltet
dass er kritische Infrastruktur im
cyberraum angegriffen worden ist in
Extremfällen wird dabei das
österreichische Bundesheer zur Hilfe
[Musik]
geholt Jäger Gruppenkommandant mir sind
sie Mann unterstellt ich krieg am
bestimmten Bereich zugewisen den was sie
zu sichern hab man sieht Krieg in Europa
man sieht wie schnell das gehen kann das
kann jedes Land zu treffen deswegen find
dieser militärische Landesverteidigung
sehr
[Musik]
wichtig ich bin der Wachtmeister Winkler
ich bin Unteroffizier in der ABC
abwtruppe und bin tätig in kneuburg im
ABC
abwzentrum man geht in das Gebäude muss
natürlich anhand der Informationen die
man hat herausfinden wo der kampfschluss
sich befindet man muss dann auch schauen
wie weit die Verschleppung ist ist das
ganze schön andere Räume dann wird das
ganze mit unserem Messgeräte detektiert
dann beginnen die weiteren Verfahren
sprich ob wir da eine Probe nehmen
müssen ob der ganze Raum dann
dekontaminiert gehört Menschenrettung D
durchführen ist alles in dem Bereich
dann
machbar im theoristischen Bereich
definitiv werden das immer eher
prominente politische Ziele sein aber im
militärischen würdest auch definitiv
auch größere Städte Dörfer oder fragile
Infrastruktur treffen deswegen muss man
da eben gut vorbereitet
[Musik]
sein dass man irgendwo schierst oder
dass man irgendwie eine Konfrontation
hat aber das ist nicht nicht das einzige
Verteidigung hat ja verschiedene
Facetten z.B dass man jetzt Präsenz
zeagt dass man dadurch eben schon
verteidigt namals wachtmisterf und die B
wasserpionier
[Musik]
bootskomandant die Angriffe finden
alltäglich im Endeffekt statt es gibt
nicht nur die Infanterie den Banz und
den Flieger so wie man es früher kennen
das worldwide web ist heutzutage zu
einem der wichtigsten und
entscheidendsten Kriegsschauplätzen
geworden wenn man den Cyber war verliert
hat man auch in der konventionellen
Kriegsführung keine
[Musik]
chanceen na ja in erster Linie mache ich
das für mein Land ja inin Österreicher
und so kann ich was zurückgeben ja bin
nicht umsonst beim Bundesheer deswegen
würde ja me Land mit mein Leben
verteidigen